Let me start with a somewhat trivial
example just to contrast the notion of
fast memory obliviousness
to fast memory awareness.
Consider the problem of
sequential reduction.
Let's start by reviewing
the fast memory aware version.
It scans the list in units of size L
to match the memory transfer size.
Notice that l is an explicit variable or
parameter of the algorithm, but
at least the algorithm is I/O optimal.
It performs just n/L transfers.
By contrast, suppose that the hardware
in the operating system managed fast
memory for you.
For instance, maybe you already know
about caches from the OMSCSHPCA course.
If so, you could regard this hardware
managed fast memory as a cache.
Or, maybe you know about
virtual memory and
translation look-aside buffers from
the OMSCS operating systems class.
If so, you could imagine
the operating system and
the hardware acting in concert to move
pages of data from disk to main memory.
They would swap pages out of main
memory, which would be the fast memory
in this case, back and forth to
disk whenever main memory is full.
In either case, the purpose of
the automatic systems is to let you
write the conventional algorithm.
It's a lot simpler, because fast
memory is automatically managed,
the algorithm doesn't need to
move data around explicitly.
The automatic system takes each read or
write,
checks that the data is already in fast
memory, if so, it returns the value and
otherwise it goes to slow memory
in order to retrieve the value.
And if it retrieves the value,
of course,
it'll do transfers in blocks of size L.
Notice that the conventional algorithm
makes no references to z or L.
Thus, we say that the algorithm
is oblivious to fast memory.
So if we had a good model of how
automatic data movement works,
we'll be able to analyze
conventional algorithms, and
say how many memory
transfers would they incur.
Given such a model, we'll be able to
analyze conventional algorithms, and
in this case show that the conventional
way to do a reduction also incurs just
n/L transfers.
This discussion points
out two questions,
which is what this lesson is all about.
First, what should we assume about
how the automatic system behaves?
Secondly, can we create
algorithms without z or
L parameters that nevertheless match the
performance of algorithms that do use z
and L parameters?
That's what we mean by oblivious,
though, of course,
we mean it in a positive sense.
One last note about terminology.
We will by convention refer
to this fast memory as cache.
It’s just a shortcut.
Sometimes cache really means say,
virtual memory backed main memory for
disk.
It helps that it's a lot easier to say
cache oblivious than automatic fast
memory oblivious.